guys hear that man
you guys hear that
can you hear that
that's the sound of greatness
guys should be able to hear that just
just close your eyes and take it in
just close your eyes
and take it in
want you guys
take it in man
the day
has finally come
to play
halo infinite multiplayer
in its entirety
so let's check stuff out a little bit
now keep in mind my so my throat's a
little bit messed up so
you know
if
if i'm not being as extra as i usually
am that's because of that
[Music]
oh
look at that
i like that
oh look at the coloring man
looks really nice man
it looks really nice
got a little bit of stuff going on right
now
look at you guys man
does the does the audio sound good
between both of us
i'm curious that the audio sounds good
between both of us
looks like this is like the common one
let's just jump in the game man oh can't
play the campaign
let's play quick play
how many maps
multiplayer
custom games maps 343 industry
one two three four eight it looks like
ten ten maps
to maps is a pretty good thing to start
out with 10 maps is pretty good
we got 10 guys 10.
what's the price for the game i don't
know
i'm not entirely sure what the price of
the game is
i'm not entirely sure man not entirely
sure
yeah it's it's a couple more than i was
expecting so that's good
micro transactions price
um
so
looks like um
this sets 2000
[Music]
got a little bit of set going on that
1500
how much is the battle pass
looks like the battle pass is
a thousand that's probably ten dollars
[Music]
so delilah says multiplayer is free to
play but the campaign is standard retail
i don't know how people are going to
feel about just the campaign being sixty
dollars
they might have a little bit of a hard
sell there
when does it update on the playstation
store
i don't know man
i don't know when it updates on the
playstation store
[Music]
ten dollars is not bad ten dollars is
not bad ten dollars is a pretty good
price
that's for like the beta uh the the
battle pass
or 25 to have a a
a level boost
all right so let's go guys i haven't
played a whole lot of this i need to get
right back into it
i feel like you're a little bit faster
than you are
yeah i see you
all right come on
look you ain't gonna move
i'll definitely kill you
if you're not gonna move i will kill you
reloading
a conqueror's weapon in your hands wow
so
it's got a little bit of a
a little bit of a hit to it
all right so let's get that health back
let's jump up here man we got to get we
got to start
doing some damage
does it do that one over here somewhere
oh i thought i had him there
it's in two days
what do you mean hard self
and people
attacked it too
people definitely attack fraternal for
being a full price game power items
wow grenades should i need to be a
little bit more cautious when i do stuff
we have achievements i don't believe we
yeah there is achievements
why to go over those after this game
all right come on man let's go
all right
where is that dude
oh my god
change your dead zones what you mean by
dead zones
hopefully we'll get some other uh
members of the lord in here soon
let me snatch that
quiet what button is it's right bumper
i would have been mastered without that
over shell
what's going on guys
i feel like you're faster than we were
in the beta
just a little bit faster just a little
bit faster i do feel like we're a little
bit faster than we were in the beta
[Music]
well the grenade almost had me
it almost had me chat
oh so they they tell you with the power
items they're pretty loud about it too
we're gonna stick to the outside skirts
of the mat because uh
i'm trying to stay away from multiple
fights now i don't want to get hit by
multiple people
a red letter day indeed
yeah yeah yeah i know i don't have much
ammo
we're not saying i have much ammo
let's go get this dude over here
come on where'd he go
there's got to be someone i can hit
yeah
how tragic
i tried to get away man
how's he on i just get a blue screen you
gotta reset your xbox
got to reset that xbox
i got to get this aim a little bit
better
[Music]
aim a little bit better man
you guys keep them busy i'm going around
going around town
what is that gun
what is that gun that gun is ridiculous
we're getting stomped over here man
power items incoming yeah poor
battlefield you know um
ea
played the the lottery and they lost it
looks like
power items now available where'd that
dude go
you play stupid games you win stupid
prizes i suppose
i gotta learn this map a little bit
better
and not fall off things
i will get to the chat because i see
some of you talking real spicy in that
chat
i will get to you momentarily
you guys gonna talk real spicy aren't
you
man where is everybody i think i've went
around the map twice
looks like they're on that side let's go
get them five minutes remaining there's
one right there
i knew that was a very big risk i don't
know what that gun does
oh god
yeah let's get out of here
a little bit too much for my taste man
let's go grab this overshield in 25
seconds
can i jump to here pretty easy yeah i
come on come on come up there
i know you want to oh he's dead
power items on the field
i don't even use this one
let's see how this goes
i tried to get out of there i don't know
what he was shooting me with
it's a pretty uh it looks like the
assault rifle
oh my god what do you hit me with
oh rocket launcher
rocket launcher guys
but it looks like we're about to win
here in a second so
after we kill this dude over here
oh come on i hit him shields
there we go
all right all right man first game
i got a challenge
so it looks like the challenge of today
is pretty uh
pretty basic
hmm
all right so let's look at these
achievements
so it looks like these achievements
might
is it all single player i mean all
multiplayer
capture the flag
now how much you want about all these
secret achievements is for the story
how much you want to bet all of these
secret achievements is for the story
smart smart
yeah that's what's up man we definitely
want you to get your stuff popping man
get the other lords in here momentarily
man
all right let's see here
i like these
oh so you can buy these for 2 000.
i'm very interested
i don't know if saul can play but i know
cog
and king will probably be here
momentarily
um right now they're doing stuff their
own but i did i did message
the chat saying that i'm in here
doing it now
whenever you guys have time oh with that
for the world you know we'll get that
going
i like these little poses that you get
when you come in
oh he snatched that fast
oh it's it's capture the flag
don't even know what this gun is but
we're gonna use it
oh my god
man i feel like you're just so fast
we got to protect
come on man i need help there's two of
them
they got the flag
can't do it all well i'm not really
doing anything in this match
there's always multiple of them
taking damage oh that weapon's only for
stunning people i didn't know
well they captured our flag because our
team isn't working together
that dude literally just threw a grenade
and bounced it off himself
[Music]
they know where you are yeah yeah yeah
flag
return
come on man
grab that
yes this is on the series x
there's he's done
this guy before i get shot from nowhere
[Music]
oh we got to get up there
we got to get up there
the enemy carrier has revealed
themselves over there
come on you guys there's one right
behind me where is the whole team
like where are they
wow
our team is just
they're not doing anything
i don't know what this dude's doing
come on you guys
gotta be a little bit more aggressive
than you're being
enemy
captured should have switched to
secondary
should have switched to a secondary
it's like there's only one or two people
going up there at a time they got like
the whole team there
geez that sensitivity is crazy
oh my god
i don't like the uh
team didn't do nothing
i've reset the xbox
yes 1600 gamers score it's a lot
how does the gun play compared to
investing pvp if it was good
i can't complain
it does it does uh it looks good man it
looks good
pvp is definitely uh
they definitely did their thing
yeah they should have been a little bit
more prepared for
for the uh
i did something i don't know what they
could have done because people had to
reset their xbox but i understand people
upset that it's not working
i mean maybe
they need to have like some kind of
system a place where they can at least
tell people live
i don't know i'm not a developer i don't
really know how any of that works
uh kill ball okay
you got to stop them from coming in
what's going on sage what's going on
brother
where are these people
oh
dropped yeah yeah yeah
he's up there dude
there you go
i don't want to go that way he knows i'm
there
round one okay round done
done round one done elimination
round two
we got to get this ball
we've got this in the bag
in chess we let the pawns go first
there's one
we have the ball
come on man let's go
let's keep this up
oh god
oh god
someone's coming that way
let's use this
how did that [ __ ] even work
oh my god
come on man
i could use some help
i could use some help
where is everybody
oh my god
not a lot of sniper action in these
matches no i'm not really a big sniping
kind of person i prefer these kind of
games actually ball dropped
hostile carrier down we have the ball
active camo inbound
halfway to victory
got to keep this dude
keep this dude going man
active camo available
wow
i didn't even think he meleed me
ball dropped
enemy has the ball
yeah you knew he was going to start to
shoot me an ally has slain the carrier
come on
oh my god
i need help i'm in here by myself
we have the ball
ball dropped
come on you guys we can do this
we can do this
we can do this guys
we can do this guys
victory
i don't know why they put that ball down
ah there we go
let's play this again man
i tried to get in on a cut and went and
got something when i got back it was
ready to update that's good man that's
good halo looking the return to the king
i might play all night when i get off
that's what's up not a lot of sniper
action alright you read that
uh updates are rolling out people just
need to be patient
i got it like the like before the show
even ended
i might need to actually
share this out you guys
[Music]
there we go
playing this halo guys
how you guys feeling about halo so far
does it look good
some of you playing it
[Music]
what you guys thinking how we thinking
what's our mindset for halo
[Music]
what is our mindset for halo
what is this
[Music]
i don't know what this means
this is nice man
[Music]
what are these
technically go it is pretty fun so far
man it is pretty funny fun
crisp i get that get them added i'm at
work streaming you but damn i wish i
i had leftover stick days sick days yeah
get into the menu but can't start to
play game looks better than i thought it
would best graphics for a free-to-play
game in a while
i think that would be a fair assumption
is there a 3v3 mode probably not
currently
here we go
oh this map looks interesting
oh
i couldn't do much
right now doing hold the zone
scoring
wish i had uh that dude's dead
wow what is that gun
that gun's out of this world man
we gotta get alpha next
wow what did he hit me going in
how are you playing
pvp
stronghold charlie lost
let's get this
hold charlie at all costs
they were trying to get me out of there
with those grenades
yeah it's definitely smooth man
oh i had no choice but to go out
oh my gosh
enemy halfway to victory we gotta take
these
the objectives has captured bravo
we've captured charlie
you got to stay at them too man you
can't just
they're taking them right after we
we take them back
come on you guys where is everybody
your team's scoring
news
acquired
oh the
thrusters they're an update that they're
up
okay
oh god yeah i like that
thrashers from halo 5 is it a is an up
is a power up
come on man
yeah i knew i was the best stuff there
your team scoring
oh my god
we can we can be nice in the chat man
the cinder shot we don't need that we
don't need to get shot by that either
drop all obtained
yeah
i saw you
could do not to him
it's definitely feeling nice like i'll
give it that it definitely feels nice
the enemy has captured alpha we've
captured charlotte
oh my god there's two of them i can't
kill everybody
there you go thank you
it's rough man stronghold bravo lost
bravo was just took so there's got to be
someone here
[Music]
they're probably going to come around
the outer skirts
what are you doing
oh man i thought i should have killed
him with me
don't see the pulling hardcore away from
mcec
i mean
people are going to try it naturally
just because it's free to play
if the if the hardcore is that
determined to play that type of game
then maybe that's a good thing
like i don't think i don't if you you're
never gonna get those players
enemy team scoring
stronghold alpha is ours your team's
scoring we're catching back up
they just gotta make sure that they
don't take these
oh my god
guys got to stop letting them take them
the moment you take it
the enemy has captured alpha
we've captured charlie
oh my god
i felt like i'm the only one pushing
enemy team nearing victory
we've captured bravo
[Music]
stronghold charlie lost
wow
defeat
yes because the team wasn't doing what
they were supposed to
oh my gosh
i was definitely lacking that game too
challengers makes
for play any match
i don't know how i feel about not
getting xp for playing the game
like i do feel like they need to change
that like i really do
i'll be right back you guys
what's going on guys um
i'm definitely gonna
i'm gonna play more of this but i'm at
the in the stream a little early but
my jaw is hurting like bad but i
appreciate everyone coming through
first time playing the halo infinite
beta and uh it was good man i can't wait
for the actual game for the campaign